now you would imagine if you ran a news
network and one of your hires one of
your employees turned out to be
criminally liable for lying you might be
embarrassed but they're not embarrassed
over at CNN just today Jeff Toobin who
works over there scrambled to ante
McCabe's defense watch this
Andy McCabe is a CNN contributor he is a
colleague and a friend to many of us who
work here this is an extremely unusual
prosecution and EEMA Cade had the right
to speak to reports he also has an
impeccable record as one of the most
honored and successful FBI agents of his
generation I mean it is really difficult
to understand even what the lie is here
the alleged lie the yeah the alleged lie
the alleged propaganda you're getting
from CNN imagine if that channel at
MSNBC too frankly applied the same level
of skepticism to the news how about to
the Russia hoax we might not have wasted
two full years on what turned out to be
a completely fraudulent story
jean-pierre oh host justice with judge
Jeanine she's all through the author of
the new book radicals resistance and
revenge which thanks to her many loyal
viewers is right up there at the top of
the New York Times list we're really
honored to have you tonight as we always
are so judge give us the state of play
for Andy McCabe you're Andrew McCabe you
wake up this morning what are you facing
well what you realize is that the grand
jury that was investigating him has been
called back it's been called back
because the upper echelon of the FBI the
Deputy Attorney General has made a
decision that he will be accountable for
the charges that the Inspector General
has recommended what we don't know
tucker is whether or not there will be
additional charges but at the very least
what we know is lying to the Inspector
General lying to the FBI at least three
times under oath and four times and you
know what people are not mentioning is
he was given the opportunity to take it
back because they knew what the truth
was
he was so arrogant he didn't want to
take it back but this is the first of
many to fall and I talked about this in
my book when I talk about rats deserting
the ship
now as Katherine just said and I heard
it for the first time they are waiting
to see what's going to happen who is
going to point the finger at whom now
now there's a lot at stake you know the
gig is up they know that the the
Attorney General now bill Barr is
serious he's serious he's going to make
sure that people are accountable and the
amazing part of this when I listen to
Jeff Toobin over there at CNN trying to
spin this thing I wonder how many people
Andrew McCabe has recommended
prosecution of for the very same thing
that he himself will probably be
indicted for as well he should be if
indeed that is true and let me just say
he's presumed innocent that cloak events
innocent surrounds him but this would be
the first of many because what they did
at the FBI in an attempt to overthrow a
sitting president and in an attempt to
begin a counterintelligence
investigation at that level I mean even
bill Barr the Attorney General says it
just doesn't hang together so I think
this is going to be one of many what's
so striking about this story it is the
first time in memory in recent memory
anyway that I can recall someone from
permanent Washington from the permanent
bureaucracy / political class being at
least potentially held to the same
standards that that class holds everyone
else so there are lots of people who've
been caught up recently in criminal
investigations because they lied but
nobody from the FBI has been since I can
remember can you no I can't but you see
the drumbeat has been so consistent out
there the American people want justice
they're not looking for anyone in
particular they need to know that Lady
Justice is blindfolded that whether
you're above the law or below the law it
doesn't matter you're entitled to the
same level of justice and that could be
that could mean punishment as well as
exoneration and in this case it has gone
on for far too long
we know that the Russia collusion
delusion was the Russia collusion
delusion was just that delusional and is
the mainstream media and you know the
leaks from the FBI continued to spin
that we realize that this country was
fractured
because people like Andrew McCabe wanted
to spin information start investigations
start the the claim with a special
counsel that Donald Trump was colluding
they use their positions of power that
we entrusted to them and they broke the
law that we gave them the authority to
recommend prosecution for this is the
ultimate test of the American justice
system and God I'm hoping that it works
yes he's a dirty cop liberals used to
used to despise dirty cops oh yeah not
anymore apparently thanks judge great to
see you we're gonna see you later
tonight on final exam yeah we're the
returning champion